foreign
[Music]
with that I took it low I took it to a
whole another register went low you know
a lot of people don't realize I can
growl but I gotta bust it out sometimes
to remind the people that yes my vocal
cords as a man are fully intact and I'm
ready to use them at a moment's notice
sometimes on a whim
so here we are today
God damn great day yesterday huh
well I don't know if you oh yeah dude
great day yesterday remember yesterday
barely barely yeah we you know Casey is
very busy here he does a lot of things
this was just particularly on my mind
that I kind of meant to text it to our
thick boy group chat but I wanted to say
that
the day started off very stressful for
me
uh finishing an audition before I had to
come in and ended by the time I left I
was in such a good mood and felt so uh
uplifted by the days and by the the days
of events and in particular the guests
but also in particular the people I work
with so I'm gonna Express gratitude
about that but didn't want to interrupt
what you were saying
remember
um you remember yesterday
this I'm gonna give like give me a
little like your impression of yesterday
did it stand out to it all or am I the
crazy one here yeah no totally it was
awesome I mean uh Robin black yes Robin
black are you garbage guys we're in oh
yeah so I didn't have much interaction
with the ru Garbage Guys I was prepping
the shoot doing other stuff editing
stuff but the robin black thing um was
awesome he's just a brilliant mind with
regards to MMA and yeah his breakdowns
are awesome and uh he was a really nice
guy I thought the two shoots we did were
tremendous did you were you aware of him
before yeah okay without any context and
I recognized his voice so I'm like oh I
must know this guy from somewhere but
having no context and getting to
overhear those conversations so much
resonated with me
um because he's somebody who thinks
about
um you know inherent bias when he's
doing MMA commentary
um falling into the same patterns
linguistically which can also then
affect how you think about things
um you know he was he he was just
obviously a deep thinker and somebody
who he has fought professionally I'm not
sure exactly I know there's like some
Canadian promotion but he's also a
musician by trade and Entertainer and I
thought that brought out a side of
Brendan in these conversations that we
might not normally get to see because
he's either dealing with one or the
other you know the The Comedians or the
fighters and
it made me think about how there is so
much overlap between
Athletics and martial arts specifically
and anything else that's that's creative
like stand-up comedy like acting
whatever and our tendency is to kind of
separate these two things like
especially in a tribal way uh you're not
you're a football player you can't be an
actor I've received forms of that and it
doesn't Define me it doesn't that's
something I still have bitterness about
but like it happens right people go you
can't be a stand-up you're a fighter you
can't be a fighter you were a pro
wrestler you know for CM Punk or
whatever the case may be
but you can take many of the same
approaches you can take many of the same
habits you can take many of the same
philosophies towards uh working towards
excellence and thinking about
how you pursue excellence in the
combination of sort of like your
intuition and your analysis is one way
to put it you know where you like repeat
things so many times that you're doing
this subconsciously and you use some
great phrases that I'm gonna draw blank
on if I try to recall them right now
about
uh your motor patterns right he was they
were they looked at the fight flashbacks
and he picked three really interesting
ones that even that is worthy of
discussing because when people come out
and say I want to look at these three
fights well he was allowed to look at
not just you know fights that he'd had
but
fights throughout the history of MMA
what would you do if you had a fight
night flashback
and you could pick three fights in the
history of MMA to look at what would be
the organizing principle we talked about
it on the fighter and the kid how Brian
likes Wars and Brendan likes sort of uh
spectacular moments and Robbins was
these are the biggest events
so to speak
that rocked the MMA world or they have
some place in the the historical record
of MMA as being super significant right
so he's got the
um Connor Eddie Alvarez fight he's got
the Ronda Rousey Holly home fight and
he's got the mouths of it all Ben askren
fighting I thought those are really
interesting picks and again because he
explains his philosophy on
giving
these moments their their credit
and that kind of reminds me and overlaps
with this notion of gratitude because we
have a tendency
especially an MMA I know people go like
well Conor's falling off he sucks now
but didn't he wasn't he one of the most
spectacular fighters to ever exist and
sort of change the game
permanently irreversibly
with what he was able to do and so to be
dismissed after that as if that wasn't
an achievement that you can retire on
is kind of insane
um
and that applies to so many things
outside of fighting but people you know
what have you done for me lately they'll
that we have a recency bias that makes
us go
you know what was the thing you did
today or even to find people by their
worst moments like in Conor's case
you know hitting an old man or whatever
whatever worst case scenario you would
look at for Conor to Define him by
I think it's a valuable exercise for
anybody to challenge themselves if you
have a negative opinion about something
where you want to dismiss somebody's
accomplishment
before you do that
attempt to give them credit for the best
thing that they've done right because I
always feel like
when I'm on the receiving end of
criticism whether it's in bad faith or
whatever if I feel like this person
can't also give me credit for my
positive qualities or the best things
that are going to acknowledge something
that I objectively do well well I'm not
going to take your criticism that
seriously because if you
have a narrative or a conclusion from a
feeling or whatever it may be typically
you'll have a feeling about something
that leads you to say I don't like this
person right now and then what you do is
reverse engineer your position from that
emotion to make it seem
rational when it's anything but and
that's a bright you know that happens to
me but that's a broad perspective on
kind of how the human mind tends to
operate
and knowing that you can try to at least
push back or tug against it a little bit
to try to reman object well nobody's
truly objective but it's just always
worth at least acknowledging
the the pitfalls of the human mind
and he's a guy who like I listening to
and talk you're like God damn this guy
is so
aware of how the mind works and um
you know on a scientific note not just a
philosophical level although that too
but
I think it's one of the deepest
conversations about MMA that perhaps
I've ever heard so that put me in a
super good mood and talking to that guy
and just hearing somebody
go yes there are certain principles
about MMA or music or stand up or any
kind of art that transcend just the
specific genre or format of that
creative output and
that also applies to fighting so when
you try to reduce somebody like he's
just a fighter it's like there there is
creativity in fighting there's
creativity in almost everything there's
creativity in putting together a single
sentence and that's something that Noam
Chomsky has said so you know what are
the world's foremost linguists
uh I I believe that but it's also not my
just opinion it's like Noam Chomsky will
give you credit for forming an English
sentence or a sentence in any language
and I believe that because a lot of
people want to sort of make a binder
this person's creative this versus not
we're all creative give yourself credit
for that and and try to develop that and
recognize it in other things because to
me
that's for the sort of beauty of Life
lies if I could just get super deep for
a second
this podcast is now called Deep Thoughts
by Mark Hawley
in a British accent that's so vague
what is it is he going to make a
decision about speaking of what Chapel
just came back from
England
mine likes that
mine likes the eggs and beans
you had a great time why am I telling
you this go listen to Chevelle's podcast
but it was interesting to hear his
thoughts on Comedy there and the
reverence for that they have for comedy
in British culture versus America
there's some interesting distinctions I
think that people will make and I do
think
it makes sense hearing him said it's
like yeah it could be anecdotal you know
the people sort of get less offended or
whatever but it is like yeah they have a
rich tradition of of comedy and I think
they elevate it a little bit more and
say hey this isn't the thing that we're
all going to get upset about because
don't watch it then right
are you Garbage Guys I just want to give
a shout out to them they're they're some
of the funniest guys I've ever seen like
and I get to be in the room with the
king of the sting as they did their
episode and then afterwards
we flipped the script on them we uh we
sat them down at the thick boy table and
said are you thick I asked a series of
questions for those of who you who don't
know the ru garbage podcast format is
essentially like it's an interrogation
you know uh are you a garbage human and
or are you trashy they look through your
entire life and ask you very specific
questions uh like you know is your is
your grandma's lawn AstroTurf or things
like that hyper-specific
to determine whether or not
you're an absolute piece of white trash
or not or any race of trash but uh these
guys are white so
supernaturally funny and these are guys
who like watching him in the room with
Chris D'Elia too
and watching his happiness for where
they're at In This Moment In Time that
they're on the come up that they are
in fact
getting their moment of shine after so
many years of where they they have the
stand-up chops they have
The Experience requisite the opportunity
meets the preparation to provide this
pivotal moment and if you go check out
their podcast you're going to see what
I'm talking about
it's one of these formats where he's
like oh damn that's good
because it creates drama you want to
know the answer to it and you also get
answers that in a podcast you're not
just going to get people sort of relying
on their standard tropes of I have this
funny story when people ask you such
specific questions about how you were
raised you might not have thought about
that for 20 years you know for example
drove me nuts when I was a kid but my
parents would hang garbage bags like
like grocery bags empty grocery bags
on the handle of the uh you know under
the sink the cabinet of the sink
instead of a garbage uh you know can or
something like under the sink instead of
just a little uh garbage container a
trash can they'd hang that I thought
that made us look poor
and it was very like we're in this nice
house and you're gonna put this there
like like we're homeless or something so
that like for instance that drives me
nuts lots of little things like that
that maybe you didn't think about that
drove me nuts but there's so many little
things that it's like oh this detail of
my life
tells uh you know a lot about class in
America we don't think about that a lot
in England they do and you can hear it
in the person's voice as soon as they
speak
with their accent that reveals
everything about the upbringing
and also allows people to fake their way
through life
I know you guys are probably thinking
wow Mark has a little pep in a step well
that's true and I always have a little
pep in my step when I'm on that dare
Kratom buddy where do I get my creative
from Happy Hippo would I trust any other
source of Kratom absolutely not could be
just a bunch of green stuff in a pouch I
don't know
but happy Hippa hooks it up with the
pills the powder and guess what else
they do of the shots right you've heard
of Five Hour Energy how about happy
hippocratum that lasts for like five
hours it's really cool
I'm gonna urge you to try it fire up
your brain use it as a nootropic start
low figure out your dose get cracking
with it okay you can go to happyhippo
herbals.com and use promo code a thick
boy with three c's for 20 off for the
rest of your life
yeah it's generous deal with it I know
you guys are probably thinking to
yourself at this point wow Mark was that
shirt custom made to fit your muscles no
it's actually an oak and stone clothing
shirt uh you see a lot of people were
under the impression also that they only
make button-up shirts Well turns out
they don't you could wear this shirt to
the gym why because it's form-fitting
it's stretchy
it's got the Oak and stone label on
there but nothing too flashy it's just a
classy black shirt that's versatile okay
remember Oak and stone clothing is made
with the athlete in mind so if your dude
who like goes to the gym or maybe you
don't but you just have a naturally
athletic frame because you're in your
early 20s and things uh haven't gone
South for you in life and you haven't
started drinking and overeating multiple
times a week and destroying your
physique and then blaming it on your uh
testosterone decline naturally you know
even though when you went to the doctor
they said hey if you stop drinking beer
you know that would be something you
could reverse it with
Oak and still crying
Oak and stone clothing is the brand for
you I do legitimately love their stuff
and whether you're an athlete or just a
guy in his early 20s uh who doesn't work
out check it out use promo code hella
for 10 off and then tell me
after you get the clothes
Mark you were right they are that good
okay what are we doing now we're going
to talk about uh
oh yes overheard during the Amber Heard
trial
sensational
Casey I know you followed along as
religiously as I did
which means you probably also followed
the follow-up of the trial
he says no he just doesn't even wants to
look cool that's what I'm getting from
the situation he just doesn't want to
admit the fact that he was obsessed with
the Amber Heard trial he can't admit it
you know it's okay dude we still love
you either way it's not a big deal to me
that you were literally skipping work
calling out sick
it's like oh yeah funny because I just
drove by your apartment looked in the
window and you were just like this on
the floor in front of the TV looking at
the Amber Her trial with my feet up and
then I actually have a picture on my
phone what okay you know what I don't
want to embarrass him thanks I'm not
somebody who just embarrasses people on
podcasts
what I thought was interesting from this
because yeah we are going to follow up
I'm going to talk about it as much as I
want to talk about the Amber Heard
Johnny Depp trial because her lawyers
got out like before the as the verdict
was being read they were going on TV
going no this is terrible for everyone
they went on uh amber heard's lawyer
went on TV and said this is a huge
setback for women what is it though
she says social media influenced the
outcome of this trial uh did it though
so
she made sure to get right out in front
of that narrative and try to portray
something that to me it's the most
disingenuous slimy thing to do of course
you're a shitty lawyer so you're gonna
do that but you have no moral compass or
principles so of course you're going to
do that you are a garbage person but in
a different way
psychologically you're a garbage person
whatever your name was uh amber
hertzware
it was interesting to then hear the
rebuttal of uh Johnny Depp's legal team
they came out and said on Good Morning
America whatever and in response to
these direct questions you know do you
think this is a setback for women
the response was domestic violence
doesn't have a gender
boom
conversational TKO because what she
attempted to do there again with this
linguistic sleight of hand and I think
manipulative people they're always going
to do this and this is why it's
important to me to always examine
language and how people respond to
things and be able to point out these
little details that people
will swap out it's a setback for all
women why didn't you say all domestic
abuse survivors because that would make
people think well who is the domestic
abuse Survivor
if it's a setback for all well we can't
deny I am hurt as a woman
but we could potentially deny she's in a
domestic abuse Survivor because a jury
of her peers said she was lying about
that so
it's it's a road that you don't want to
go down linguistically speaking
social media influence the trial how did
it influence the trial right in what way
was the trial misrepresented on social
media which was the cause of this guilty
verdict in the eyes of Amber heard's
lawyers or at least in the words of
Amber herzler I don't even know she
believes it wouldn't surprise me if she
doesn't but she was certainly sticking
to her talking points which crumble very
quickly under scrutiny even a little
pushback there was a great moment Casey
when the guy goes uh on the talk show
she went to
one of the guys I guess was a former NFL
player and he goes you know after uh we
lost a game when I was in the NFL
we would look at game tape to say
what did I do wrong what could I have
improved upon
that that I could take into the the next
game and do better
what did you do wrong in this case
to watch her crumble
her her answer after she gathered her
thoughts and stopped stumbling was some
of these people threatened to put her
baby in a microwave
that was a response to what could you
have done better in this trial she goes
well I
we're crazy
always got to look for that right you
make a good point and somebody goes
you're crazy
conversational TKO
is that it do you I can do the whole
podcast on the Amber her truck
you don't know this but uh Casey's off
screen please please stop please I don't
know the eight hours of Youtube footage
I watch every day doesn't cut it
do you realize that sometimes I do a
hell of Chef Harley and it's not even
stuff I make what yeah no I'm gonna I'm
gonna come right out and say this
I am about to do a hella Chef Harley
for food that I didn't physically
prepare myself because the boundaries of
this segment on the show transcend my
kitchen
they transcend my refrigerator my
freezer my pantry do I have a pantry or
do I just have cabinets is does a pantry
imply walking into a space surrounded by
Dry Goods I don't know I didn't have a
pantry growing up and if you told me you
had a pantry I'd be like what is that
and they're like that's where we keep
all the Pop-Tarts dude you notice how
every time you come over
and you eat all our food we have more
food in the pantry because we're not
sick animals like you living day to day
because you have three boys that drink
gallons of milk at a single sitting and
drink dozens of Cokes in a single day
because you're addicted to sugar and
nobody's monitoring you
take from that what you will yes those
are true stories
don't give children unregulated access
to sodas
that's my real point there because we
don't Auto regulate we just go sugar
sounds good I'll have 40 of them the
only mechanism that's going to stop me
from drinking soda is throwing up and
that's only going to make room for more
soda
back to the point of this
I actually do this it was telling a
funny story or what I think if it's a
funny story which is my younger brother
not to throw him under the bus but uh he
had a problem with surprise puking
it would happen on car trips so just be
like you know driving to Wyoming for a
family vacation all of a sudden car sick
getting car sick but what do you do when
your car's sick say hey yeah I'm sick
could you pull over yeah probably a few
minutes before you puke yeah
so Andy would not do that Andy would
just go blah we're like oh we found out
you're sick from the sound of you
vomiting in a car
and uh also the case we found out you're
sick
from The Sound Of You vomiting Adam
Marie callenders on top of your
fettuccine alfredo
true story because they keep bringing
you refillable Sprites you know oh have
another Sprite
nine-year-old child
who needs 800 grams of sugar before his
dinner arrives
so what was I talking Marie Callender's
pies that's my hella Chef fart no it's
not
um my hella Chef Harley for this week is
going to Chipotle didn't feel like
cooking the other day and I said what
can I do that's healthy you look around
you go do I go to McDonald's
do I go to Zankou Chicken there's lots
of places that are in the direct
vicinity do I go across the street to uh
you know Ralph's and get a rotisserie
chicken my calculation was I want some
meat I want something hearty I want
something flavorful I want it prepared
by someone in their early 20s who
doesn't like their job so I went to
Chipotle
and I said let me get a burrito bowl
no tortilla
no guacamole because usually when I go
to Chipotle like I have this binary
thought process of going to Chipotle
means I get a
double steak full of guac in a tortilla
that they're gonna have to double wrap
and then I'm gonna pretend like that's
not more calories so the thing I end up
getting with every single thing that's
available to me in this burrito that
can't be wrapped and is causing this 24
year old woman a lot of stress at her
job
is probably closer to 2 000 calories and
then I might get chips and guac which I
just found out is like 770 or 800
calories that's how they get you that's
how they that's how they get you
overweight
and coming back for more
this is what I did I said let's forget
about all the accoutrement let's stick
to the a brown rice let's stick to the
steak times three yeah I did that let's
stick to the black beans because I don't
rationally discriminate I'm not going to
go in there and say oh only white beans
for me just because I happen to be of a
Caucasian background doesn't mean that I
won't employ black beans to get in my
stomach
so beans rice steak and a little bit of
that whatever it's called it's slipping
you know six years of Spanish and here
we are
I'm forgetting the word pico de gallo
don't even know what it means
sounds like papagaya which means a
parrot that's a great insult that nobody
uses in uh you know Mexico or any
Spanish-speaking country but you can
just say cayate Papagayo shut up parrot
and they'll be like huh but like it
might sound funny so
I once told that to a guy on a bus full
of Latinos very early in the morning he
came on and started preaching about how
evil Hillary Clinton was and even though
like sure I have my criticisms of her
too hey dude it's six in the morning
and you're talking to a bunch of people
who are on their way to work we don't
want to hear political propaganda in
2016 on this LA bus
so I said hey hey stop and we went back
and forth for a little bit and my
conversational TKO to this white man
spewing political propaganda on a bus at
6am was cayate Papagayo the place went
wild Casey is what I'm saying
the Latinos hoisted Me Above their heads
for those five minutes
I was a hero
what I'm saying is this Chipotle bowl is
just the hello Chef Harley with the most
tangents that I've ever introduced into
a single segment
815 calories triple steak my man and it
felt great like it's one of those things
where you know you go to a place you're
like and I know it's going to come with
this feeling of bloating or this feeling
of diarrhea or this feeling of
reevaluating your life because why did I
go to Chipotle and order food that's 2
000 calories when all I wanted was a
snack
this was perfect it digest it quickly I
had no issues just the steak just the
beans just the rice just that pico de
gallo
try it out sometime try not being an
[ __ ] at Chipotle ever thought about
that didn't think so
should we talk about the pro Science
Academy should we talk about
something fun like liver King meme of
the week
like I'm a chat like oh go here go there
I keep Casey on his toes
let's just click that little that little
reel
did you show me this the other day
because I this is uh liver King
clouds of the background pull out he's
curling on a surfboard and at first I
was like that is actually crazy
impressive it's a good piece of content
regardless but then I realized he's
actually wake surfing now if he was able
to swim out and catch a wave with a 25
pound dumbbell and then start curling on
it for you know what appears to be
longer than two seconds I'd be like God
damn we need to give this guy more
credit for his athleticism but wake
surfing different thing right Casey
correct right professional uh extreme
sport Enthusiast yes
and then what do we have out into that
oh it's a meme by our favorite
uh anti-liver King meme page vial of
denial
Disney Pixar's Trend story
and it's just the Liberty with Tren get
it because he does Tren funny stuff okay
let's do a Bro Science Academy because I
was going to talk to you guys about how
to work ABS people will tell me and ask
me I want to work ABS we somehow treat
abs like it's a different thing than
everything else we want to do a hundred
sit-ups we want to do
abs every day we want to treat it like
it's a somehow abs are a different
muscle than everything else my notion is
sure you have to get lean abs are made
of the kitchen they are but you can also
make your abdominals more prominent by
building the actual contractile tissue
in your stomach crazy crazy notion right
what I do is I put a bosu ball behind my
back on the floor right I lay down on it
my ass is on the floor I take the
heaviest dumbbell I can get which uh you
know I could use 110 120 maybe but I
would suggest starting with just
something that sounds heavy to you
I worked up from like 60 to 70 you know
take a plate right you put it behind
your head and you just want to be
anchored your your but where your butt
is should outweigh that weight behind
your head you shouldn't be like tipping
backwards from it
if you expand your rib cage and
basically do a crunch up to here right
that's a short range of motion but it is
very taxing to your actual abdominal
wall here and that will make your abs
become bigger over time the second thing
that I'd ask you to do
anything that you can do heavy like this
the ab machines where you go crunch
there's a Hammer Strength one that you
can manually load with plates because a
lot of these machines don't really go up
that high
the hammer shrink when you can manually
load plates on energy like you can you
can make it really tough you could do a
set of 10 to failure or less and that's
going to build your apps if you want a
six pack right screw functional strength
but that is a different thing it's like
okay if you're a baseball player or an
athlete or something sure more
rotational stuff and
uh you know do it for the actual
athletic performance nature of it but
most people like I want a six-pack make
your abs bigger because that may reduce
the appearance of your midsection by you
know you're at 12 but you look 10
because your abs are sticking out to a
degree
um
also get an AB wheel probably one of the
most important pieces of equipment for
developing your abs because it provides
this uh a possibility for Progressive
overload that's the end game of that
being doing starting from a standing
position bent over the waist and you're
you know reaching down to your toes to
start you're in a pike position to start
if you can roll out from here all the
way to flat and back up without touching
your knees or your stomach or any other
part of your body to the floor during
that whole rep your abs are going to be
insanely strong but you can start out by
going underneath doing more reps
building up to just a negative where you
roll out as as straight as you can and
then just go to your knees and stand up
again
sounds crazy I know oh my God you mean
it's not a hundred crunches in a row
every single thing
not doing flutter kicks on the floor for
three hours
crazy concept try it out thank me later
when your abs are absolutely popping
look
a lot of people been asking me people
actually have been asking me a [ __ ] ton
believe it or not because you go on
fight on a kid turns out to talk about
steroids everyone's like what steroid
should I do this isn't about that but I
will get to more of that we're gonna
have a lot of help I'm on steroids in
the future
I also decided I am going to write a
book about steroids in my voice I'm like
I don't need to do it but well you know
I'm just going to end up repeating the
same [ __ ] over and over again
um so I am going to write
in my own voice of like hey this is what
I know and also there's a million things
I don't know here's an ebook for five
bucks
just so I can send you the link instead
of repeating the same things over and
over somebody did ask me this yo Mark I
need some uh more advice which implies
by the way that I have given him advice
in the past that he likes so much that
he's coming back for more he's double
dip in his pen in The Old Company Inc is
that an analogy I don't know but it
sounds like something that people in a
corporation would say it's been a week
since I fractured my cheekbone my eyes
bruised pretty good I was wondering how
long I should wait before training again
you're going to note that I do not ask
him how he injured his eye
because it's irrelevant but I'm
realizing now God I'm a dick it's been
one week and I feel I'm losing gains LOL
I appreciate you big dog
the way he ended it with big dog
um that motivates me it's like oh you
think I'm big you get my attention
so
first I did say wow that [ __ ] sucks
in response
I wouldn't worry about a week two weeks
yeah you may start to lose a little but
I've just noticed also side note men in
general it's like I haven't lifted for
48 hours am I getting smaller I used to
be that way you'd take a week off
lifting and you're like oh my God I
shrank
chances are you did maybe if you got
sick you lost some weight or some
strength but the average guy taking off
a week of lifting or even two weeks is
not going to do too much you don't want
to do that all the time unless it's a
program d load and even then try to get
in the gym do a little bit
I preface it this is not medical advice
but I have trained with broken bones
before such as a broken rib and a broken
hand
got in a fight broke my hand doctor was
like we're gonna need to cast it up for
the whole summer I'm like sir I am a D3
college football player this summer is
where I do steroids
do not tell me this bad boy is going to
be in a cast I need to bench press
because that has a very very direct
correlation with my athletic performance
on the field
so I said [ __ ] it lift with a broken
hand which is not that bad actually
lifting with a broken rib is much
tougher because there's certain things
where it's like oh yes
flexing my abdominals and my lats in
that position
re-breaks my rib or whatever it is
doesn't feel good uh the only advice I
can go by is feel if the exercise causes
a sharp pain probably skip it if you can
control the feelings of pressure in your
face with breathing and also actively
not contorting your face I'm speaking
like this is the advice I give myself as
somebody who suffers from chronic ugly
lifting face
I would say Mark remember to breathe
it's not a competition to see who can be
the ugliest person in the gym while
bench pressing
you're trying to avoid pain and
embarrassment
so I'll set uh I wouldn't worry about a
week a two weeks in and I already say
that God damn it
two screenshots one message that's it
most of these things you're like can I
do this it sounds bad but it's like try
it out
does it hurt don't do it that principle
can apply to so many things uh you know
if it hurts a little bit doing something
on it probably will make it hurt a
little bit more speaking of which my
client Paul has had this shoulder issue
for weeks and weeks and weeks and since
I've known them and it's like maybe
related to he like you know
snap his bicep tendon which a lot of
people have you know where like shortens
up a little bit but like
doing this on a squat rack doing
um
various movements even like lat pull
Downs you could describe a burning
sensation in a shoulder
he was doing a curl of some sort the
other day doing arms and shoulders
he felt a sharp pain drop the weight ah
my God
then it kind of went away
and then pain totally gone
and then the next day like when I saw
him this morning his whole bicep was
like all bruised you know and you're
theorizing I don't know what that is he
did get a cortisol injection
uh like a week before it was that bad so
you like and I don't pretend to know
that much about the shoulder I I really
barely understand it it's it's an
insanely complex joint with so many
things going on to move your shoulder in
all these different directions so who
knows but I do know this
when you have shoulder issues things
catch and they you know there's so many
overlapping things going on there it is
possible that you reduce the
inflammation on something with a
cortisol shot it has the chance to move
back into place that really hurts
because your tendon's like
causes bruising causes inflammation but
then guess what today we're lifting no
pain in all these ways that he
experienced pain before
so what I'm saying is sometimes you need
to take a step back to take a step
forward is that the analogy here I don't
I don't know but pretty cool huh it's
satisfying to snap something into place
like ah that hurt but it ended up
bettering me life lesson
don't take my word for it
dude what else do we even have oh oh
that's right this is why we can't have
nice gyms and I'm going to show you some
things
the first one here
literally this is why we can't have nice
gyms because gyms aren't nice
this guy's working out on multiple
machines that just so happen to
literally break down as he's on them and
they're both ones that like kind of seem
like they could injure him like the leg
press snaps
the leg extension just snaps up that
almost hit him in the face
this just remind I don't know where he
is I'm not going to make an assumption
about that but like look the coloring on
the gym you know that's freshly painted
machines but I'll look around even to do
24-Hour Fitness or any of these gyms not
going to name any Zoo but like you go
did nobody think to fix this like why is
there just a pin missing from this
machine
why is this hamstring machine you know
out of service for the last three months
why is there two stairmasters and one of
them doesn't work and it's been like
that for seven weeks can we fix this it
just doesn't seem safe but I think in
general you know you get what you pay
for especially at like 24 Planet Fitness
whatever you're paying 10 50 bucks
it ate Equinox Equinox probably has a
lot of the same [ __ ] right except it
just works I would assume I don't know I
can't afford to go in there so maybe
somebody can get a free pass and come
you know I may have also been outlawed
from going there
um
because I was handing out flyers for a
gym that I was starting during the
pandemic called tree Equinox
it's just the part guys it's just the
park okay
next
oh I saw this this begs a philosophical
question
do we lift weights or do light or do
weights Lift us that is what
I believe Kierkegaard said
you saw this and said what Casey I was
like that looks difficult yeah right
because he's smooth with it his his body
is not moving as he's doing these uh
hammer strength-esque lat pulldowns
bring his hands to him as if
his body's anchored down but it ain't
and that's some skill right there so
good on you dude
next up
oh this just hurts to watch
deadlifts 405 slams it down
his headphones bounce off of his head I
believe like they're on his head yes
they're on his head and the jerking
motion of his head throws the headphones
off and it lands under the deadlift of
the the weights as the weight is
bouncing up so it's like throw your head
gets caught right there as the thing is
bouncing up and then catches boom it's
like
now life lesson there maybe you don't
need to slam your deadlifts like an
[ __ ] why not just drop them people do
the same with like they get it up and
then they like throw it back down with
their whole body not necessary that is
not 800 pounds it's 400 pounds it ain't
that much I've lifted it before and I'm
not even that strong
this guy thought was it was a funny
little caption he's doing an overhead
press in what looks like a crossfit gym
and he looks like a crossfit her because
he has short shorts on and he's training
shirtless
the caption there says when you want to
be jacked but also have a six pack uh
Shredded and also not to roids but also
do 300 kg deadlifts but also run a five
minute mile but also train and compete
in MMA but also hand walking and
backflips but also just focus on
mobility and flexibility
this made me think of how
we want so many different things in the
gym and now you can go for many things
at once but like and Crossfit does a
pretty good you could really dial in
your programming and achieve a few
different things at once but you got to
remember that the most efficient path to
anything like putting on muscle is doing
strength training right the moment you
try to go well I also want to run a five
minute mile it's just going to make both
of those paths
a a little bit longer and harder right
because you're pulling in opposite
directions I remember that guy Ross
Edgeley I think is his name like fitness
band of the world he swam around Great
Britain
in a wetsuit like a psychopath but very
impressive
he made a great point because it's like
he's also super buff you know claims to
be natural probably isn't look him up
he was like basically you just don't
want to do two opposing things right
after one another you don't want to like
lift weights for hypertrophy
and then go run a marathon without
recovering in between because then your
body's confused like wait where do I
allocate my recovery resources to
getting bigger or you know to increasing
the mitochondria in my quadriceps you
know mitochondria the PowerHouse of the
cell that's right
the one thing everybody remembers from
biology class here we have Mia Khalifa
oh yeah she's about to take off her top
psych Top Gun stop watching pornography
not only is this a perfectly executed
sketch slash troll job
by whoever made this video it's
something I think about because people
have these excuses like I don't have
time for the gym if you really ask guys
okay
did you jerk off this week how much time
oh it took 20 minutes use that towards
going to the gym find these little
things that are you know analogous to
jerking off in that they're a complete
waste of time
I don't know man I'm getting pretty good
at it
skills
um other than that you know we we waste
time in so many ways and I'm obviously
not a master of time management but I am
you're not Mark Mark Harley you're not a
master of time management
podcast it's the only thing we haven't
started the podcast on time in a month
we haven't started broadcast on time
ever since before we started the podcast
even when Mark would think about the
podcast it was always starting three
hours late
in his dreams Marcus
shooting at 3 pm when he was supposed to
be in a tent
um so but I am I do try to be honest
with myself of like oh yeah you don't
have time to lift like you made that
excuse in your head I don't have time
but what else did you do you know
scrolling social media watching a TV
show staring out into space
contemplating your life and where things
really went wrong that could be 20
minutes of your day that you could swap
out with lifting
think about it now we have a few funny
memes these are awesome like Loosely gym
related me spend 720 bucks on a cycle
shipping 10.99 yeah
that classic you know what would you
call that skeptical hippo eyes or face
or whatever he's like
I don't know about that
that we have uh this is great Arnold's
legs are swapped out with his girls
uh standing at this hot girl hanging on
him Arnold in his prime it says when
your girl has bigger legs than you
I thought that was funny because that is
actually an issue these days like girls
go to the gym and do legs three times a
week and Jim Bros still often don't do
legs and I'm not judging you because
legs suck and I have naturally big legs
I don't even try to have them you know
to make them much bigger but I also
worked them out a lot for football Etc
so it was built into my programming I
didn't think about in terms of like I
need to get my quads bigger right
if you don't want to get your quads
bigger and then also squats suck and leg
press sucks and everything about working
legs sucks
don't do it
right your brain says your ego says your
your willingness to skirt difficult
situations and rationalize that
that's what it says in your brain but I
do think there's Merit into at least
doing something exhausting with your
life whether that's Hill running whether
that's pushing a sled or whatever
because the mitochondria is a Powerhouse
of the cells what I'm saying yeah so
Casey I just wanted to give you a little
update before we go
um
last week I asked a question
will I expose this person who's the top
or one of the top don't want to give
away his position
one of the most prolific posters on the
subreddit and I said chime in below with
your opinions let's democratize this
process turns out you guys chimed in
and you guys were right I should expose
him and that's what I'm going to do and
next week tune in to haters will say but
seriously I want to do it in a more
organized systematic way at owners back
it's this guy I want to give him
the full attention that he deserves the
attention that frankly he's been giving
me and my friends for a number of years
over the course of almost 9 000 posts so
stay tuned there will be a dramatic
reveal next week I promise you that even
if the entire podcast is just me going
into this person's entire life story
name and address occupation where he
works
some of his uh
worst posts maybe so you can figure out
like what what ethical level is this
person on and how should I
maybe you know explain to him why he's
wrong we wouldn't want to retaliate with
videos mocking this person that would be
wrong right but I can't control you
either so
tune in next week
we're going to devote an entire episode
to unmasking ah it was the groundskeeper
the entire time and I would have got
away with it too it wasn't for you
meddling kids